війна війна поділила життя на до і після
хоча після ще не
настало з самого початку бойових дій
російської агресії допомогу військовим
почав доставляти Мій брат
ми разом організовували збори касок
бронежилетів а також захистів для
бронетехніки дуже багато чого
закуплялось
збиралось дуже багато часу проводили в
дорозі в серпні-вересні місяці в мене
жили десантники ми ремонтували їм
машини вони розповідали дуже страшні
речі особливо чіпляло це катування над
нашими військовими полоненами над нашими
захисниками і ще страшніше було за те що
знущання над місцевим населенням як вони
його
грабують тому матеріальне
підійшло перестало бути
цінностю сьогодні ти маєш все завтра ти
не маєш вже нічого найважче в
волонтерських поїздках - це дорога
додому Коли ти збираєшся коли ти збираєш
машину
вантажиш на передову То ти дуже
натхненний
уважний щоб нічого не забути щоб
максимально зібратися
ти привозиш ти все
роздаєш але ти не
відчуваєш гордість за це
якусь
результативність Бо це така крапля в
океані тих проблем які є
їх ще вирішувати і
вирішувати і вертаючись просто в тебе
порожнича і думки про те що ти будеш
завтра далі робити збирати максимально
щоб допомогти основна задача волонтера
це є збереження життя наших захисників
Бо життя - це найцінніше що
є в кожного захисника є сім'я
друзі і
смерть це
трагедія
тому
забезпечення
найнеобхіднішим
захисників для бою для відпочинку є дуже
важливим вони більш впевнені вони
підготовлені тому вони більше зважають
на свою безпеку
культура культура - це окремий
фронт яким ніхто довгий час на Луганщині
і Донеччині не
займався великий Інформаційний потік був
саме з
Росії чим і вплинув
на любов до Русского Мира завдяки людям
культури які приїжджають з всієї
України Ми
створюємо
діалог з
людьми це дуже важливо щоб люди бачили
саме діячів
культури бо культура є
самоідентифікація артисти
письменники дуже охоче їдуть зі мною бо
вони знають що я їх привезу туди де їх
почують
будуть до них будуть тягнутись проїхавши
Тисячі кілометрів Сергієм
жаданом дивлячись на всю ситуацію
культурну Ми вирішили створити
фонд фонд який допомагає саме освітнім
закладам школам дідсадкам дитячим
будинкам Ми не можемо втратити це
покоління
підростаюче покоління бо діти - це наш
фундамент майбутнє України Харків Харків
є прогресивне місто Харків столиця
студентства науки культурна
столиця Я зроблю все щоб Харків став
справжнім європейським містом зручним
для життя не умовним а саме зручним нова
влада яка рекламувала себе як
реформатори
інноватори
наділі виявились профанами повними
профанами так звані нові
обличчя виявилися старим бюрократичним
болотом Вони вимагають
реваншу але я не хочу реваншу я буду
боротись проти Реванш і я хочу щоб в цій
боротьбі поруч зі мною були сильні люди
такі які є європейські солідарності і це
велика честь що в цій боротьбі зі мною
вперед сильні люди
fore